i saw the doctor strange man and i want
to talk about it i tweeted about it
put it on instagram
rest in peace mcu
marvel cinematic universe
rest in police rest in peace what do i
mean by that
okay
not a fan of this movie i did not like
it now let me put it in context okay so
you're talking about 13 years of
maybe like 75 hit rate of movies leading
up to avengers end game
you know i i wasn't a fan of all the
movies in in that that went through this
process you know i thought the first
captain america was a
it was just okay
uh you know i thought iron man 3
terrible i thought thor 2 dark world
could have done without it
um there was just there was just some
movies along the way leading to end game
that was just like so so so enjoyable
maybe saw him once i was okay with it
even some of the avengers movies like
avengers age of ultron could have done
without it but
you know what it led up to this
spectacular ending the whole thing had a
purpose the mcu had a purpose it was
defeating thanos
all the stories were connected our minds
were like this is great i love all this
we were invested in every character we
knew even the smallest characters we
knew it branched off into other movies
we just it was just great like the whole
thing was great i'm glad i lived through
it it was a spectacular time in movie
making for superhero movies and it was
fantastic thumbs up big woo-woos for the
cinematic universe the marvel cinematic
universe
but after that it is now dead
[Music]